konferenz herzlich willkommen zur
pressekonferenz nach den gremien heute
mit dem cdu 40 ministerpräsident armin
laschet und generalsekretär paul signac
jetzt gibt es erst ein bericht aus den
gremien im anschluss gibt es gelegenheit
für fragen
ich habe meine damen und herren wir
haben heute im präsidium und dem
bundesvorstand der cdu intensiv über die
wahlergebnisse von gestern und über das
weitere vorgehen gesprochen
es steht völlig außer frage dieses
ergebnis kann darauf und wird die union
nicht
zufriedenstellen wir haben zwar im
schlussspurt einer aufholjagd geschafft
und rot-rot-grün verhindert aber
zugleich gibt es schmerzliche verluste
es hat nicht gereicht für platz eins das
war unser anspruch das war unsere
ambition und mein glückwunsch geht an
die
mitbewerbenden parteien die zugelegt
haben bei dieser wahl ein ergebnis unter
30 prozent ist nicht der anspruch der
union als volkspartei
besonders drastisch sind die verluste in
ostdeutschland ausgefallen die gründe
für dieses wahlergebnis sind
vielschichtig auch das ist heute in den
wortmeldungen der vielen vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen des
bundesvorstands deutlich geworden und
natürlich weiß ich auch dass ich meinen
persönlichen anteil an diesem
wahlergebnis habe wir haben besprochen
dass wir das alles intensiv aufarbeiten
das werden wir tun in einem
strukturierten prozess mit den
landesverbänden mit den kreisverbänden
und mit anderen an der basis der
generalsekretär wird dazu gleich noch
etwas sagen
und das werden wir tun
ganz gleich ob wir am ende dieses
prozesses in regierungsverantwortung
sind oder in der opposition auch in
regierungsverantwortung
muss eine erneuerung der union
stattfinden auf allen ebenen und das ist
das was wir dann gemeinsam besprechen
werde
das ist die verantwortung die wir
gegenüber unserer partei haben aber es
gibt auch eine verantwortung für unsere
wählerinnen und wähler eine
verantwortung für unser land die
wählerinnen und wähler die cdu und csu
gewählt haben wollen dass wir auch
verantwortung übernehmen und regieren
und wir sind der überzeugung dass eine
führung eine regierung unter führung der
union das beste ist für unser land und
auch diesen wählern fühlen wir uns
verpflichtet
und deshalb haben wir gestern unsere
bereitschaft dazu erklärt das ergebnis
der bundestagswahl stellt nämlich nicht
nur die union sondern auch deutschland
vor große herausforderungen
bei fast jeder bundestagswahl war am
ende klar eine partei hat einen klaren
regierungsauftrag hat eine mehrheit die
muss regieren und die andere hat die
oppositionsrolle zugewiesen bekommen für
uns können wir sagen keine partei kann
aus diesem klaren ergebnis für sich
einen regierungsauftrag ableiten auch
wir nicht auch das habe ich gestern
deutlich gemacht
auch die spd nicht es ist ein moment wo
gerade die beiden großen volksparteien
die den anspruch haben müssten um die 30
prozent zu liegen mit demut vor den
wähler treten müssen und sagen müssen
nein diese großen volksparteien die über
30 prozent bei früheren wahlen immer
gehabt haben haben diesmal dieses ziel
nicht erreicht die einen bei 24 und die
anderen 25
und deshalb ist jetzt der wahlkampf
vorbei keiner sollte so auftreten als
wenn er alleine entscheiden könnte wie
er eine regierung bildet und deshalb
sind gespräche mit möglichen partnern
jetzt erforderlich wir müssen uns da auf
augenhöhe begegnen wir müssen auch
gegensätze überwinden zwischen
unterschiedlichen politischen strömungen
eine nächste bundesregierung wird ja
aller voraussicht nach drei große partei
familien miteinander verbinden müssen
und das hat es in dieser form nach einer
bundestagswahl in deutschland bisher
auch nicht gegeben klar ist kanzler wird
in deutschland der der eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag hinter sich bringt
so ist unsere verfassung so ist unsere
staatspraxis seit gründung unseres
landes und kanzler kann auch nur der
werden dem es gelingt gegensätze zu
verbinden und ein gutes gemeinsames
projekt für die nächsten vier jahre zu
entwickeln
der bundesvorstand das präsidium der cdu
ist sich darin einig dass wir zu
gesprächen für eine sogenannte jamaika
koalition bereit stehen und meine praxis
als regierungschef jetzt war es immer
dass sich jeder partner auch
wiederfinden muss in einer solchen
koalition dass jeder auf sein profil
entwickeln muss das nicht alles nur auf
die person des regierungschefs
zugeschnitten sein darf sondern dass
jeder partner mit seinen themen auch
vorkommen muss eine koalition
ist keine zwangsehe und ist auch keine
arithmetik wo man einfach addiert wie
viel passt denn zusammen und am ende
sind das über 50 prozent sondern eine
koalition muss ein politisches projekt
sein wo auch das ist ein gegensatz zur
großen koalition jetzt alle den willen
haben und auch die lust haben etwas
positives für das land zu gestalten und
nicht ständig den eindruck vermitteln
dass man eigentlich gar nicht regieren
will und dass das eigentlich alles
freudlos ist deshalb glaube ich dass wir
zu einer gesellschaftlichen breite mit
einem jamaika-bündnis beitragen könnten
dafür sind zwei schlüsselbegriffe
prägend das eine ist zukunfts koalition
das andere ist nachhaltigkeit
deutschland muss modernisiert werden
deutschland braucht eine koalition für
mehr nachhaltigkeit und das in jeder
hinsicht
nachhaltigkeit heißt klimaschutz
nachhaltigkeit heißt aber auch
nachhaltige finanzpolitik teile
finanzpolitik zu lasten künftiger
generationen auch das muss eine künftige
koalition prägen wir brauchen mehr tempo
bei digitalisierung der planungen wir
wissen alle dass das alles viel zu
langsam geht und eine neue koalition
muss sich dieses ziel setzen und wir
brauchen auch das wichtige anliegen dass
wir zu wirtschaftlichem wachstum wieder
zurückkommen das ist ein besonderes
anliegen der fdp das wir teilen den
grünen teilen wir das engagement für den
klimaschutz und die umwandlung unseres
industrielands zu einem klimaneutralen
industrieland zum weiteren vorgehen wir
sind im gespräch wir werden die
gespräche sicher auch noch formalisiert
in den nächsten tagen fortsetzen aber
hier ist mir wichtig das darf nicht das
klein klein sein dass wir aus früheren
sondierungen kennen
vier wochen lang sondieren mit
verhandlungen über jeden kleinen komma
strich
mit vielen eckigen klammern was alles
nicht gelöst ist und am ende dann eine
gescheiterte sondierung kann nicht das
verfahren dieses mal sein wir brauchen
gespräche aus denen deutlich werden muss
trauen sich die jeweiligen partner das
zu das gemeinsam zu machen ja oder nein
das ist ganz wesentlich eine frage des
vertrauens man wird die inhalte
abgleichen und dann vielleicht sehr bald
auch klarheit haben mit wem man
koalitionsverhandlungen aufnimmt
das war das was ich in nordrhein
westfalen macht habe was meine erfahrung
ist auch in einer regierung viele themen
die man im koalitionsvertrag verabredet
spielen in den vier jahren häufig keine
rolle wir gestern einmal das beispiel
genannt pandemie war keine frage die im
koalitionsvertrag eine rolle spielte sie
hat zwei jahre
der politik dominiert davor war es die
flüchtlingskrise davor war es die
weltfinanzkrise alles dinge die nicht im
koalitionsvertrag standen aber die
trotzdem im moment als es darauf ankam
klar gemacht haben die akteure die da
regieren haben so viel vertrauen
zueinander dass sie diese krise zusammen
bewältigen und das ist die voraussetzung
um eine gute koalition zu machen und das
werden solche sondierungen ergeben
müssen unabhängig natürlich von den
großen themen wie wirtschaftswachstum
wie sozialer zusammenhalt wie klimakrise
dazu wird man ein paar rahmenbedingungen
natürlich abstimmen müssen aber
entscheidend ist trauen sich die akteure
des gegenseitig zu jetzt ein neues
projekt für das land zu beginn
zu dem was wir der partei weiter man
spricht dass gleich der generalsekretär
mein dank gilt normalen wählerinnen und
wählern auch den kandidatinnen und
kandidaten
wären manche wahlkreise verloren von
engagierten kolleginnen und kollegen die
gekämpft haben aber die am ende nicht
gewinnen konnten
die enttäuschung dort können wir alle
verstehen wir werden jetzt gemeinsam
sehen wie wir auch individuell bei denen
sind die ihr mandat verloren haben wenn
dann gilt auch allen wahlkämpferin und
wahlkämpfern in
mecklenburg-vorpommern und in berlin wo
er ebenfalls gestern gewählt worden ist
danke auch den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter hier im hause die letzten
wochen wirklich großes geleistet haben
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass wir als
team antreten dieser teamgedanke ist mir
auch in der weiteren entwicklung der
union sehr wichtig und heute haben auch
noch mal die strömungen der partei sich
artikuliert die sagen wir wollen
vorkommen der christlichsoziale flügel
stark karl josef laumann
der wirtschaftsflügel der seine punkte
gesetzt hat und der liberale und
konservative flügel hatte ebenfalls
sprecher heute man konnte daran erkennen
die volkspartei wird jetzt definieren
wie sie sich in zukunft aufstellt die
erneuerung kann stattfinden
sie kann auch in einer regierung
stattfinden sie muss so war auch wenn
wir regieren dringend umgesetzt werden
wird sie mir ja vielen dank meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren auch ich
möchte mit einem dunk beginn an die
wählerinnen und wähler aber natürlich
auch an die wahlkämpferin und
wahlkämpfer überall in deutschland für
die union und an die kandidatinnen
kandidaten die vor ort ein unglaublich
engagierten wahlkampf geführt haben und
gekämpft haben vor ort für die idee der
cdu und dafür danken wir ihnen ich danke
den mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern ebenso
des konrad adenauer hauses die an
unglaublich engagierten einsatz gezeigt
haben die tolle arbeit geleistet haben
die tag und nacht da waren um alles zu
tun damit wir einen guten wahlkampf
machen können an ihnen hat es nicht
gelegen und ich möchte an dieser stelle
auch an die denken die es nicht
geschafft haben die nicht in den
deutschen bundestag wiedergewählt wurden
oder hinein gewählt wurden trotz ihres
unglaublichen einsatz ist und deswegen
ist es wichtig zu sagen dass die gründe
nicht vor ort zu suchen sind sondern
woanders und deswegen müssen wir dieses
wahlergebnis aufarbeiten
und dieses aufarbeiten bedeutet eine
klare und schonungslose analyse es gibt
aus meiner sicht überhaupt keinen grund
irgendetwas schön zu reden die verluste
die wir erlitten haben im vergleich auch
zur letzten bundestagswahl
sie sind bitter und sie tun weh und
deswegen müssen wir uns genau auch
bewusst sein wo wir wie viel verloren
haben wenn ich zum beispiel an den osten
denke dann fragt mich das sehr um die
frage spielten die themen die für die
menschen dort eine rolle spielen
ausreichend hatten sie ausreichend platz
in unserem wahlkampf die frage der
besonderen strukturen dort wie geht es
dort jetzt weiter nachdem viele mandat
verloren gegangen sind das ist etwas was
mich sehr beschäftigt und ich finde dass
die frage wie ist die cdu im ost
aufgestellt eine ganz ganz wichtige ist
deswegen braucht es jetzt eine wie
gesagt schonungslose konsequente analyse
dieses wahlergebnis ist es ist nicht mit
einer sitzung beendet und diese muss
auch brutal offen sein
deshalb müssen wir die kampagne
evaluieren wir müssen vor ort uns auch
der diskussion stellen das ist heute
auch noch mal in der sitzung klar
geworden und das werde ich auch als
generalsekretär tun vor ort zu sein mit
denjenigen sprechen auch die jeden tag
vor ort wahlkampf gemacht haben das sind
die kreisverbände stellvertretende
kreisvorsitzende die ortsvorsitzenden
diese gespräche diese konferenzen werden
jetzt ganz ganz wichtig sein und bei
allem respekt auch für die gewählten
gremien die ganz wichtig sind eine
aufarbeitung und eine wahlanalyse kann
nicht in erster linie nur durch die
gremien erfolgen sondern sie muss die
ganze partei ein bin insbesondere die
basis die ich gerade angesprochen habe
und ich finde wir müssen auch mit den
vereinigungen sprechen der die
unterschiedlichen flügel und strömungen
unserer partei repräsentieren mit all
ihren themen insbesondere denke ich da
auch an die jungen menschen die hier
gemeinsam mit der jungen union tollen
job gemacht haben bei unseren connect
team die frage wie wir auch junge leute
erreichen treibt mich sehr sehr pump und
deswegen braucht es in der frage der
partei die klare offene analyse aber
eben auch erneuerung für die zukunft der
union als volkspartei der mitte und das
werden wir jetzt tun in einem sehr
strukturierten prozess worüber wir auch
noch in dieser woche beraten werden und
dieser prozess muss sehr intensiv sein
und wie gesagt alle einbinden und diese
sitzung war geprägt eben von
selbstkritik
selbstkritik in bezug auf die verluste
gestern abend aber sie war auch geprägt
diese sitzung von einem großen
bewusstsein von verantwortungen
staatspolitischer verantwortung für
dieses land es gibt mehrere optionen
eine neue regierung zu bilden und wir
haben diesen geist heute gespürt dass
wir mit einem starken wahlprogramm von
cdu und csu angetreten sind und bereit
sind diesem land zu dienen gemeinsam mit
anderen partnern auf augenhöhe
um eine mögliche zukunft ein mögliches
zukunftsbündnis für sicherheit für
klimaschutz und für innovationen auf den
weg zu bringen aber das werden die
gespräche zeigen und diese beiden punkte
waren heute kernbestandteil und diese
aufgabe ist jetzt herausfordernd beides
ist herausfordernd aber beides ist auch
wichtig und deswegen werden wir die
nächsten tage und wochen sehr intensiv
arbeiten
vielen dank ich habe sehr viele fragen
einige davon können wir an den
beginnende mit frau heescher vom zdf und
danach der herr rinke bitte vorher
fischer
sie haben gesagt dass sie mit demut vor
den wähler treten warum machen sie nicht
den anfang und bekennen dass sie zweiter
geworden sind wir können sie das vor
sich moralisch rechtfertigen trotzdem
platz 1 zu beanspruchen nein ich
beantworte ich platz eins besinnt platz
zwei aber
eine koalition bildet sich an sach
inhalten und aus der mehrheit des
deutschen bundestages
und das kann man nur in gesprächen jetzt
klären wer denn im deutschen bundestag
eine mehrheit hat
und wenn der eine 24 hat und der andere
25 hat nicht automatisch der der 25 hat
eine mehrheit im bundestag das ist ja
nur durch sach gespräche löw war am ende
über 50 prozent der mandate im deutschen
bundestag zu bekommen und das ist die
aufgabe von der jetzt alle
demokratischen parteien stehen es ist
sehr gut dass dieser prozess ohne die
extremen funktionieren kann unter den
demokraten in der mitte aber wenn ich
auch die signale aus den anderen
parteien wahrnehme ist genau der wille
da diese gespräche zu führen und dazu
ist die cdu bereit
dann herr rinke von reuters bitte
lasst sie haben gesagt dass sie
sondieren wollen mit grünen und fdp es
gibt aber gleichzeitig die warnung dass
eine jetzt stark geschwächte union ihren
markenkern dann endgültig aufgeben
könnte fürchten sie nicht dass das genau
die konsequenz ist und sie zwingen wird
letztlich selber den stecker sind ihnen
bei diesen sondierungsgesprächen ein
ja wir werden natürlich unseren
markenkern nicht aufgeben für ein
klimaneutrales industrieland einzutreten
für
sicherheit in deutschland einzutreten
für ein europäisches deutschland
einzutreten
für tempo bei der digitalisierung und
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen einzutreten dass man die
kernthemen des wahlkampfs das halte ich
mit beiden partnern sowohl mit den
grünen als auch mit der fdp für lösbar
dann bitte frau lehmann von der neuen
wasserrinne zeitung
herr lässig für wie groß halten sie denn
den rückhalt er jetzt im vorstand und
präsidium für sie jetzt in die
sondierungen reinzugehen und wie groß
der rückhalt in der partei dafür dass
die parteichef bleiben
der rückhalt des präsidiums und des
bundesvorstands ist ohne jede
gegenstimme für diese gespräche erfolgt
ist nicht formal abgestimmt worden aber
am ende hat es eine zusammenfassung den
konsens aller gefunden und es hat auch
in der sitzung keiner daran zweifel
geäußert dass die union in dieser lage
ihre bereitschaft zur regierungsbildung
erklären muss
herr gathmann von spiegel
morgen kommt ihre neue fraktionen von
cdu/csu zusammen da steht eigentlich die
wahl eines fraktionsvorsitzenden haben
sie im präsidium vorgeschlagen dass man
auf diese wahl verzichten soll und der
bisherige amtsinhaber brinkhaus erstmal
im amt bleiben soll ralph brinkhaus hat
offensichtlich gesagt er möchte trotzdem
kandidieren was wird denn nun morgen
passieren ihre ich glaube dass ich mir
hier berichten was im präsidium war im
präsidium war es nicht so wie sie es
schilder im präsidium habe ich
vorgeschlagen dass ralph brinkhaus in
der phase dieser koalitionsverhandlungen
fraktionsvorsitzender sein soll wie wir
das formell machen werden wir im laufe
des tages heute noch besprechen aber es
ist doch korrekter trinkaus gesagt hat
er möchte antreten
der erste teil ihrer beschreibung war
nicht korrekt das
erste teil war also ich glaub gebracht
glaubt bitte nochmal gehen sie davon aus
dass ralph brinkhaus morgen als
fraktionslose ich werde eher als
brinkhaus morgen vorschlagen als
fraktionsvorsitzenden zusammen mit dem
bayerischen ministerpräsident das steht
außer frage das habe ich aber gestern
abend schon gesagt dass ich selbst für
dieses amt nicht zur verfügung stehe
ähnlich wie olaf scholz aber ich führe
die gespräche als parteivorsitz
laubholz für sie weder als
parteivorsitzende noch als fraktionschef
der auch nicht fraktionschef werden will
sondern als kanzlerkandidat deshalb
müssen wir die gespräche muss die spd
die gespräche auch über ihrer
parteivorsitzenden führen und für uns
ist klar dass sich diese sondierung
führen kann aus dem amt des
parteivorsitzenden und ich es gut finde
wenn ralph brinkhaus als
fraktionsvorsitzender an diesen
gesprächen beteiligt ist und das werden
wir morgen der fraktion vorschlagen aber
das muss einmal nachfragen für für die
klarheit dass er kommissarisch im amt
bleiben so geht das wenn wir bis morgen
klären in welcher form wir diese
abstimmung machen mir ist wichtig dass
der ralph brinkhaus dabei ist und für
die fraktion an diesen gesprächen
teilnimmt was anlass war aber seit
gestern nie geplant insofern war die
einleitenden bemerkungen heute morgen
gab es da irgend eines boot- gegeben
falsch meine meinung ist seit gestern
dass es richtig ist in dieser phase der
ungewissheit wer denn in zukunft regiert
oder der opposition ist so eine lage
haben wir ja in deutschland noch nie
gehabt dass da kontinuität in der
fraktion ist und dass diese kontinuität
durch ralph brinkhaus verkörpert wird
herr blank von dpa verlottert ich muss
noch mal nachfragen zu den möglichen
gesprächen die anstehende gestern doch
den eindruck erweckt dass man auch
parallel mit herrn scholz zusammen mit
den grünen und der fdp als union
verhandeln könnte heute hört sich das
etwas anders an dass man erst abwarten
ob die gespräche von herrn scholz
erfolgreich sind hier ist das so und was
besprechen sie denn sie haben gesagt wir
haben mit herrn lindner schon gesprochen
und werden noch mit frau besprechen geht
es da schon am inhalte oder was werden
sie da besprechen oder haben sie
gesprochen danke ich habe gestern nicht
den effekt als wenn ich erst mit dem
schoß reden sollte oder ob ich irgendwas
abwarten
nein ich habe nichts gesagt mit herrn
scholz sondern dass sie parallel mit
herrn scholz mit den grünen und der fdp
reden mit wem es sich dann lohnt
koalitionsverhandlungen auf ich weiß
nicht wann wer mit wem mit wem herr
scholz redet ich habe für uns gestern
deutlich gemacht dieses ergebnis wenn
man auf platz zwei liegt ist kein
regierungsauftrag und wir erheben keinen
anspruch
auch wenn es so geschrieben wurde mein
wortlaut gestern war sehr präzise es
gibt keinen anspruch mehr platz zwei hat
hat keinen anspruch aber es ist eine
situation wurde eine 24 unter anderem 25
hat und die beiden kleinen partner
gesagt haben das ist nicht automatisch
so dass einer für sich beanspruchen kann
er redet sie es mal mit den kleinen und
deshalb an fdp und grüne gestern
deutlich gemacht sie wollen erst mal
miteinander reden was ich in ordnung
finde und es wird parallel es gibt
gespräche mit jedem erst einmal über die
über das weitere vorgehen und dann wird
irgendwann entschieden wie geht's denn
strukturiert weiter aber da gibt es
jetzt keine reihenfolge gestern gab es
gespräche heute gibt es gespräche morgen
gibt es gespräche es wird immer wieder
gespräche geben formalisiert wenn ich es
richtig verstehe was die wettbewerber
sagen treffen sich jetzt erstmal fdp und
grüne
deshalb ist nichts anders als gestern
und es soll es anders als morgen es ist
eine lage die deutschland so noch nicht
erlebt hat und auf die nebenbei neben
all unseren klein-klein ganz europa
blickt wir müssen auch ausstrahlen dass
deutschland eine regierungsfähige
regierung bekommen wird eine
handlungsfähige regierung weil die
aufgaben in europa ja nicht warten und
natürlich alle darauf achten dass
stabilität in deutschland herrscht
deshalb ist das mit muss das mit hohem
verantwortungsbewusstsein auch diese
gespräche geführt werden und das ist
meine absicht und unsere bereitschaft
als union unseren beitrag dazu zu
leisten
dann frau dunst von der 1 in der mitte
rnd genau
herr laschet warum entscheiden sie sich
dagegen dass herr brinkhaus wie es
bisher üblich war zum anfang einer
legislaturperiode der der
fraktionsvorsitzende für ein jahr
gewählt wird sie haben ja gesagt für die
phase der koalitionsverhandlungen was
macht das so unsicher ihn heute schon zu
bestimmen und wie reagieren sie auf die
mahnungen von ihren cdu parteikollegen
wie zb herr kretschmer und herr haseloff
jetzt noch inne zu halten und einmal in
ruhe zu überlegen wo die union sich
wiederfinden muss nämlich unter
umständen bei einer erneuerung in der
opposition
das haben die heute nicht vorgetragen
sie erhalten es für richtig an der beide
dass die union ihre bereitschaft erklärt
sich dieses wahlergebnisses nun mit
anderen parteien zu sprechen und zu
sanieren wie eine nächste
bundesregierung gebildet wird das war
heute einhellige auffassung der beiden
von ihnen zitierten und zum anderen in
welchem verfahren für den
fraktionsvorsitzenden wählen habe ich
eben gesagt ist noch nicht klar wir
werden darüber heute noch gespräche
führen
ja weil wir darüber gespräche führen
müssen weil das eine außergewöhnliche
situation ist weil man normalerweise am
tag nach der wahl weiß ob man regierung
oder opposition ist so ist es bei allen
wahlen in deutschland in der regel dass
man nach dem wahltag weiß sind wir jetzt
opposition oder sind wie regierung und
diese frage ist am heutigen tag noch
nicht beantwortet und deshalb müssen wir
jetzt auch unseren partnern in den
gesprächen gegenüber signalisieren die
cdu und die csu seien handlungsfähig und
deshalb werden wir auch den weg des
fraktionsvorsitzenden gemeinsam jagen
dann noch 24 23 fragen dann bitte der
herr delfs von blumenberg
was machen sie denn eigentlich jetzt mit
ihrer mit ihrer aufgabe in nrw also wenn
sie jetzt in der tat in gespräche hier
in berlin mit den verschiedenen parteien
eintreten werden sie ja kaum mehr zeit
haben und energie die
regierungsgeschäfte in düsseldorf weiter
zu führen und wenn sie jetzt auch nicht
für den fraktionsvorsitz kandidieren was
passiert dann eigentlich mit ihm wenn
diese gespräche hier scheitern also wenn
es kein regierungsamt in berlin gibt
also ich habe in diesem wahlkampf sehr
darauf geachtet all die wochen und
monate dass ich meine aufgaben als
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen
sehr ernsthaft weiter führer bis hin zu
jeder kabinettssitzung und zum
bearbeiten jedes vorgangs trotz eines an
spannenden bundestagswahlkampf und
deshalb können sie davon ausgehen dass
ich das auch in der nächsten zeit bis zu
einem wechsel im amt des
ministerpräsidenten in vollem umfang
machen werde
dann die vorletzte frage an herrn otto
von zeit online ja hallo herr laschet
gerne eine ja nein antwort von ihnen sie
haben das so verklausuliert angedeutet
aber können sie ausschließen als
als als vizekanzler unter olaf scholz in
einer regierung einzutreten
wir schließen überhaupt nichts aus unter
demokraten aber eines ist doch klar
diese gespräche finden und gerade nicht
statt es werden gespräche stattfinden
vor allem mit fdp und grünen
und ich glaube die andere variante es
keine die jetzt auf den
prioritätenlisten der beiden großen
volksparteien die sie einmal waren steht
hermann da vorne von der süddeutschen
zeitung wenn ich das richtig sehe ganz
hinten die letzte frage dann
herrlich etwas was passiert jetzt mit
dem zukunftsteam gibt es das noch ist
die zukunft des teams in die bis gestern
oder geht weiter
zukunftsteams prozent zugestimmt
bedaure dass jalloh nicht den wahlkreis
spandau
gewonnen hat hätte die
bundestagsfraktion bereichert
und
wie wir jetzt weitermachen wie die
akteure einige sind ja mit des
bundesvorstands die klima union wird
auch wenn wiege winter leider den
wahlkreis bremen nicht gewonnen hat eine
wichtige rolle natürlich auch in
möglichen gesprächen für eine
jamaika-koalition spielen also jeder der
der frau durch mercedes mitglied des
deutschen bundestages so können sie
jeden einzelnen
abrufen jeder wird auch in der
neuaufstellung in der reform in allem
was wir jetzt in der union planen seine
rolle spielen wenn ich nur ein satz nur
noch dazu ergänzen können wir haben
gerade ja im bundesvorstand dazu
gesprochen auch über die arbeit der
strukturen satzungskommission einige von
ihnen erinnern sich als wir über die
frage repräsentanz von frauen in die
frage wie sieht die zukunft der partei
aus diesen prozess müssen wir jetzt umso
mehr weiter vorantreiben also diese
erneuerung und da wird natürlich
diejenigen die jetzt auch in dem
zukunftsteam waren mit all ihren ideen
und kompetenzen müssen da er eine rolle
spielen und natürlich diejenigen die in
der breite der partei jeden tag arbeiten
sodann habe ich doch noch zeit für zwei
fragen denn herr strauß bitte von der
saarbrücker zeitung
las ich wollte sie mal nachfragen wie es
ihnen überhaupt geht wie verarbeiten sie
emotional diese derbe niederlage sie
sind ja eine rheinische frohnatur prallt
das alles an ihnen ab oder würden sie
sich am liebsten verkriechen also wie gc
naja ich hätte gern auf platz eins
gelegen
und dass dieses jahr ein
besonders intensives ist gibt ja viele
analysen wer hier am meisten
auch an attacken und hassattacken und
ähnlichem entgegengenommen hat das schon
etwas was einen berührt aber es war uns
ja immer klar dass ab dem moment wo
angela merkel das amt verlässt alle
kräfte von rechts und links wenn mir am
anfang immer eher stark von rechts
inzwischen auch von anderen verhindert
wird dass jemand von der cdu kanzlerin
das habe ich auch zu spüren bekommen
ich hätte gar nicht erst auf platz eins
gelegen aber die verpflichtung wenn man
so knapp hinten liegt jetzt weiter an
einer guten lösung für eine gute
regierung zu arbeiten da hat mich heute
das präsidium und der bundesvorstand
einhellig unterstützt und das gibt einem
in solchen momenten da noch die kraft
diesen auftrag zu erfüllen
dann die letzte frage an die damen in
der mitte nehmen genau sehr gut
er lacht ich würde gerne nochmal zu den
gesprächen kommen zu den jamaika
gesprächen diese gegebenenfalls führen
wollen sie haben gesagt dass man sich
auf augenhöhe begegnen muss kann die
union aus dieser position der schwäche
heraus überhaupt augenhöhe erreichen
wenn sie sagen dass grün und gelb jetzt
gerade schon gespräche führen sieht das
dann nicht eher danach aus als würde das
gespräche seien die unter grün gelben
gnaden geschehen die beiden früheren
kleineren parteien haben sehr gute
ergebnisse erzielt aber die frage ist ja
führt man mit 24 prozent ein gespräch
aus der position der schwäche oder der
stärke und mit 25 prozent ein völlig
anderes gespräch also olaf scholz und
ich sind finde ich zur gleichen demut
aufgerufen in der wirkung scheint das
anders zu sein aber auch mit 25 prozent
hat man nicht den anspruch ich bin der
nächste kanzler und das müssen wir mal
gerade gucken wie wir die anderen mit
dazu kriegen sondern darf würde ich
ebenfalls empfehlen auf augenhöhe mit
jedem potenziellen partner zu sprechen
und wenn herr walter borjans ist
sein eigentlicher parteivorsitzende olaf
scholz er kündet die fdp mache voodoo
ökonomie oder was auch immer heute
morgen ich weiß nicht ob das die
augenhöhe ist und der gesprächs stil ist
den man im moment braucht für uns ist
jedenfalls der wahl kam mit dem
gestrigen tag beendet und wir sind jetzt
in der phase eine stabile regierung für
deutschland zu ermöglichen und das geht
nur und das hat mich immer geprägt mit
respekt vor dem potenziellen
koalitionspartner
und dieser respekt ist übrigens auch
wichtig egal ob der groß oder klein ist
in nordrhein westfalen ist der abstand
zwischen uns und dem koalitionspartner
ein wesentlich größerer und trotzdem
kann man respektvoll miteinander reden
den anderen seine punkte machen lassen
und auch deutlich machen dass man nicht
am liebsten alles alleine macht sondern
dieser teamgedanke auch in einer
koalition tut gerade deutschland mit dem
was jetzt ansteht gut
vielen dank herr laschet vielen dank
vielen dank fürs kommen dankeschön